Now that we’re in 2020, the start of a new
decade, some things have changed in the laptop
world, and some things haven’t.
Just like last year, people are searching
for the perfect laptop to buy for their needs,
and just like last year, our purchasing recommendations
haven’t changed between these two laptops.
So before we go through those recommendations
once again but with a bit of updated information,
I first wanna go through what’s changed
since last year, and that’s the price!
So that MacBook Air was actually the legacy
2017 model with the super huge bezels, horribly
outdated TN display, outdated specs, but overall
decent laptop!
And I believe that there’s one reason why
it’s the best-selling laptop, and that’s
because it’s the cheapest way to get a MacBook,
currently on sale for only $750.
Now what all of those people who bought it
might not realize is that the updated MacBook
Air with the much better design, display,
newer specs, bigger trackpad, and more, is
also available for just $759 Renewed on Amazon.
Yes, that’s the 2018 MacBook Air with the
lastest design, for only around $750 which
is unheard of because the retail price at
launch was $1100.
Now a lot of people steer clear from Renewed
models because they’re not brand new, but
for only $750, that’s a steal!
And plus, Amazon gives you a 90-day money
back guarantee if you have any issues with
it, which is much more than the regular 30-day
return policy.
But this ordeal doesn’t end there.
We actually found a MacBook Pro Renewed for
even cheaper, only $740.
However, it’s the 2017 dual-core model,
not the latest 2019 quad-core model that we
recommend for anyone doing creative work on
their laptop.
On the plus side, the older model features
physical keys instead of the new Touch Bar,
which some prefer.
So now let’s get into comparing the MacBook
Air and the MacBook Pro for 2020.
First off, if you’re gonna be buying one
of those Renewed models, keep in mind that
they’re both dual-core models so performance
shouldn’t differ that much, and both of
them will be a great choice.
But if you’re doing any kind of creative
work, I’m talking Photoshop, lightroom,
video editing, programming, working with Logic
Pro, or anything else like that, we fully
recommend going with the 2019 MacBook Pro
with the quad-core processor.
That is going to give you so much more performance,
in fact, the base model gives you the best
bang for the buck in terms of processor performance
for the cash, even beating out the 16” MacBook
Pro.
Now if you don’t really care much about
performance any you just want a very good
reliable laptop, the MacBook Air is an excellent
choice, and it actually has a few perks over
the Pro.
It’s got 12 hours of battery life instead
of 10 on the Pro.
The wedge-shaped design slants the keyboard
downward for a more comfortable typing experience.
It’s more portable, weighing a quarter of
a pound less than the Pro.
It gets physical function keys, which a lot
of people like over the Touch Bar.
And of course, you also get the gold color
option which you don’t get on the Pro.
Now one thing to keep in mind is that both
of these feature the butterfly key switches
which have had issues in the past.
If you want to steer clear of that, we are
expecting new models of these laptops coming
with an updated keyboard possibly some time
this year, but there’s no guarantees.
The MacBook Pro, of course, does get a few
perks over the Air, like the larger trackpad
that’s more convenient.
It gets a brighter display with better color
accuracy for things like photo and video editing.
It gets better quality speakers, and most
importantly, much better performance.
So to sum up which MacBook you should buy,
if you do a lot of typing, you need the most
battery life you can get, and you don’t
really care about performance or any type
of editing or creative work, then the MacBook
Air is going to be perfect for you!
And if you like a bit more of a premium MacBook
with some extra horsepower, better speakers,
better display, and you do any kind of creative
work, 100% absolutely choose the MacBook Pro
over the Air.
And if you want the best, most powerful MacBook
ever made, the newly redesigned 16” MacBook
Pro is a game-changer with incredible amounts
of performance.
We’ll have our purchasing guide links to
the best deals on all of these MacBooks down
in the description below, and if you want
to see a deeper dive into the MacBook Air
and MacBook Pro, watch that video right over
there.
And If you’re not already subscribed, click
that circle above to do so now.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!